l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement
je vous rappelle que dans le contexte de
la crise actuelle la conférence des
présidents a établi des règles
dérogatoires d'organisation de nos
séances de questions ne sont présents
qu'en nombre limité de ministres et
outre le président du groupe ou son
représentant les auteurs des questions
les questions ayant le même objet sont
regroupés chaque question faisant
l'objet d'une réponse spécifique le
nombre de questions et réduit en
revanche les temps de parole sont les
temps usuels deux minutes par question
et autant par raiponce réplique ou
contre réplique éventuellement comprises
afin de limiter au maximum les effectifs
des personnels présents
je vous indique que la liste des
orateurs dont vous avez eu connaissance
n'est pas affichés sur les écrans
pendant la séance
je vous remercie de votre compréhension
enfin les règles sanitaires désormais
habituel continue à prévaloir notamment
les mesures suivantes nettoyage des
micros en cours de séance je vous
rappelle qu'il est demandé de ne pas
poser les mains sur les micros il
utiliser les micros différents respect
des distances entre les participants
entrée sortie échelonnée
nous commençons notre séance par des
questions portant sur la crise du que
vides 19 en général et notamment le
thème de la santé
la parole est à madame virginie duby
muller merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre je veux
commencer cette question en rendant
hommage à notre personnel soignant
mobilisés sans relâche
épuisé mais debout et à ces femmes et
ces hommes qui en dur comme ils peuvent
la vague épidémique et nous pouvons
faire beaucoup pour les y aider
monsieur le premier ministre les
immunologistes sont aujourd'hui formel
le diagnostic par les tests fait
cruellement défaut en france avec
seulement cinq mille tests par jour l'
oms a expliqué à raison qu'on ne pouvait
pas combattre un incendie les yeux
bandés
le dépistage est le meilleur rempart
pour endiguer le corona virus comme
l'illustrent les exemples sud coréens et
allemand allez vous enfin mettre en
place une politique de dépistage massif
et testé prioritairement le
sonel soignants et les forces de l'ordre
en première ligne face à l'épidémie
notre pays manque également cruellement
de masques de protection
l'heure n'est pas à la polémique le
temps du bilan viendra
ma question est simple comment
sommes-nous passés de 1,4 milliard de
masques en 2012
à seulement 145 millions à la prise de
fonction d'olivier ferrand avec un temps
de retard vous commencé cette semaine à
livrer de nouveaux masques mais le
coronavirus ne vous a pas attendu
souvent oublié je veux vous parler
aujourd'hui de nos aînés qu'ils soient
dans les ehpad ou qu'ils bénéficient de
services d'aidé à domicile
les retours du terrain sont claires
certains soignants manque de masques dès
lors il se met en danger et met en
danger malgré eux la vie de leurs
patients c'est notamment le cas en haute
savoie
alors que nous avons le taux d' attaque
du virus le plus fort de la région
auvergne rhône-alpes
ce sont d'ailleurs des entreprises ou
des collectivités telles que le
département de haute-savoie qui pallie
vos carences monsieur le premier
ministre
quelle est votre stratégie pour produire
et distribuer en grande quantité et dans
les plus brefs délais de nouveaux stocks
de masques le en même temps monsieur le
premier ministre est moins que jamais
adapté en période de crise
nous attendons des mesures chocs
d'ampleur et vous pourrez compter sur
notre soutien pour les voter je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole de
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
de bill miller vous avez posé beaucoup
de questions en une question je crois
que je serai amené à répondre moi-même à
beaucoup de questions aujourd'hui j'ai
peut-être d'abord commencé par saluer
comme vous l'engagement de tous les
soignants qui sont à l'heure à laquelle
nous débattons dans les hôpitaux dans
les cabinets de ville sur le terrain en
train de sauver des vies parfois au
péril de la leur vous l'avez dit la
grande famille des soignants la grande
famille des médecins a été plusieurs
fois en deux hier c'est extrêmement
douloureux pour notre pays c'est
extrêmement douloureux pour les français
et il n'ya évidemment union nationale
pour saluer l'engagement de nos
soignants sur le terrain ainsi que
l'engagement sans faille de toutes
celles et tous ceux qui depuis plusieurs
semaines maintenant au quotidien sans
relâche sans jamais renoncer
sont au contact des français pour
permettre à chacune et chacun de
bénéficier des soins et des services
indispensables pour leur vie du
quotidien sur la question des tests
namibie mineurs j'en ai parlé hier et
samedi lors des conférences de presse
nous réalisons actuellement plus de cinq
mille tests par jour nous sommes au
dessus de la moyenne européenne
l'allemagne est au dessus de nous
aujourd'hui encore mais elle réalisé
entre 10 à 12 mille tests par jour et
pas 160000 comme j'ai pu parfois le lire
ou l'entendre
qu'importe l'objectif je les dis il est
très clair tester tester tester l'appel
de l'organisation mondiale de la santé
est entendu comme nous avions entendu le
premier appel de l'om s lorsqu'elle a
lorsque la plaie pendant les stades 1 et
2 anneux testé que les nouveaux cas
apparaissant sur le territoire à ne
testez que les personnes fragiles à ne
testez que les soignants nous sommes
désormais parfaitement mobiliser un fake
l'ensemble des biologistes de notre pays
et du monde entier pour pouvoir à la
fois développer un test de sérologie
pour permettre de déterminer qui a été
malade et qu'il n'a pas hérité par le
moyen d'une prise de sang est là c'est
sans limites des dizaines décembre des
centaines de milliers de tests pourront
être faits chaque jour également pour
développer un test plus rapide et plus
simple que le test très compliqué qui
passe par des plateformes de pcr avec
des réactifs complexe qui n'est
disponible dans 120 établissements de
notre pays et que nous sommes amenés à
renforcer dans les jours et les semaines
à venir
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur olivier faure merci monsieur
le président monsieur premier ministre
puisque nous sommes en guerre il faut se
donner les moyens de la guerre rien ne
serait pire que d'annoncer un péril sans
se donner les moyens nécessaires pour le
vaincre il faut d'abord soutenir les
premiers de trancher les soignants
sariel agroalimentaire agente des
services publics d'en avoir la priorité
pour l'obtention des moyens de
protection
en l'absence de masques de gants de gel
seules les activités vitales devrait
être maintenu on est protégé où on reste
chez soi il faut mobiliser les cliniques
mutualistes et privés êtes vous disposé
à les mettre à contribution
et quel rôle comptez vous leur attribuez
il faut une économie de guerre
êtes vous prêt à réquisitionner les
industriels pour fabriquer massivement
des masques des tests des respirateurs
et de la chloroquine allez vous
nationalisez des entreprises comme
luxfer ou famars qui dispose à savoir
faire unique préfabrication des
bouteilles d'oxygène médical ou de
production de molécules puisque nous
sommes en guerre
alors chaque jour compte chaque décision
où chaque indécision compte le
confinement d'être stricte pour nous
permettre d'y mettre fin dans les
meilleurs délais ce que nous enseigne
cette crise c'est que tous les retards
conduisent à des mesures plus brutale
ensuite monsieur le premier ministre
nous sommes prêts à aller vite à
l'effort prêt à faire la guerre aux
virus avant que le virus nous impose la
médecine de guerre
alors monsieur le premier ministre
faites vite
la parole était monsieur olivier viron
ministre des solidarités de la santé
monsieur le député olivier faure à
l'effort aller vite
c'est ce que nous faisons depuis le
premier jour un exemple que j'aurais pu
dire à madame du meneur c'est ce qui
s'est passé en haute savoie il ya
maintenant tellement deux semaines de
cela lorsque des premiers cas sont
apparus à contamines montjoie etc
immédiatement sans aucun délai les
équipes étaient sur place pour tester
140 enfants parents parce qu'il y avait
eu cinq personnes qui avaient été
contaminés des personnes qui ont été
hospitalisées qui ont guéri du
coronavirus et un foyer épidémique qui
aurait pu s'étendre et qui aurait pu
faire de la france l'italie et ce qui
n'est pas arrivé parce que nous étions
prêts parce que nous étions préparés et
quand je dis nous c'est avant tout les
équipes des agences régionales de santé
les équipes des ministères les médecins
les hôpitaux totalement mobilisée dès le
début une fois que l'épidémie est là une
fois que le virus commence à circuler
vous savez très bien que c'est un
phénomène naturel nous devons tout
mettre en oeuvre pour enrayer sa grande
propagation c'est l'objet du confinement
et nous devons permettre à notre système
de santé de soigner dans les meilleures
conditions le plus grand nombre de
patients avec toute l'urgence qu'il y a
de libérer des places dans les
réanimations raison pour laquelle avant
même que nous ayons le moindre patients
en réanimation nous avons demandé
tous les établissements publics
mutualiste et privés d'arrêter toute
activité programmée de manière à
mobiliser des lits nous avions même
jusqu'à 2000 lits vacants dans les
réanimations de france ne serait ce que
dans l'intervalle dans la tente que les
malades affluent dans les hôpitaux ce
qui nous a permis de nous préparer et ce
qui nous permet de faire face
y compris dans des territoires qui sont
soumis à une pression hors du commun
hors du commun je pense à la région
grand est
si nous a permis de monter un hôpital de
campagne d'être capable de transférer
des patients à l'étranger chez nos
voisins que je remercie pour leur
solidarité de transférer des patients
par hélicoptère par avion militaire par
bateau dans le cadre de la corse
je peux vous annoncer que demain un tgv
est médicalisé une première en europe
transportera 30 pall 30 malades de
strasbourg et mulhouse vers des
territoires dans lesquels il y a de la
place il y a de la place dans certains
territoires tous les établissements de
santé publics et privés sont mobilisés
tout les réanimations dans la région
grand est sont parfaitement mobilisés et
pour répondre à votre question sur les
industriels ils sont tous sur le pont
raison pour laquelle nous avions
notamment fait voter l'état d'urgence
sanitaire de nous donner les moyens
légaux de pouvoir aller encore plus loin
et encore plus vite
merci monsieur le ministre la parole et
à monsieur paul christophe merci
monsieur le président permettez moi en
premier lieu également de saluer
l'investissement de toutes celles et
ceux qui se mobilisent pour lutter
contre la pandémie et qui sauve des vies
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de la santé et des solidarités
en effet je souhaite me faire ici l'écho
de tous les citoyens qui s'interroge sur
la question du dépistage du code du
colis de 19 dans cette crise sanitaire
exceptionnelle à laquelle notre nation
est confrontée la première étape logique
pourrait consister à effectuer un grand
nombre de tests de dépistage pour
déterminer en amont la continuation ou
non de nos concitoyens certains pays
comme l'allemagne ou la corée du sud ont
adopté cette stratégie de dépistage
massif
ce n'est pas le cas de la france je vous
demande donc aux sionistes de clarifier
la position du gouvernement sur cette
option
manque de matériel choix stratégiques et
sont les raisons qui ont justifié ce
choix
aussi je souhaite également vous
sensibiliser sur le manque de produits
réactifs nécessaires à ces tests
man qui n'apparaît pas homogène sur le
territoire national renforçant le
caractère anxiogène de la situation chez
de concitoyens à dunkerque par exemple
l'hôpital celui de zuydcoote les
cliniques du secteur et sos médecins ont
équipé des locaux mis à disposition par
la commune pour répondre au nombre
croissant de demandes de consultations
et soulager les
gensse du secteur mais ils sont
confrontés au manque de produits
réactifs pour réaliser des tests alors
que dans le même temps à marseille on
propose un dépistage du coronavirus à
tous ceux qui le souhaitent à travers
cet exemple comment expliquer à nos
concitoyens qu'il n'y a pas de rupture
d'égalité incompatible avec la mission
même du service public il nous faut
rassurer les français
enfin monsieur le ministre en parfaite
association avec l'ensemble des
collègues du groupe u10 agir et
indépendant et à particulier mes
collègues de la raudière et décampent je
me dois de vous interpeller sur le
manque de moyens dans le secteur médico
social dans les ehpad certes mais aussi
dans les établissements en charge des
personnes en situation de handicap
les services de soins à domicile ou de
l'ensemble de la politique de l'aide
sociale tous confrontés au manque de
masques de gants de gel monsieur le
ministre je sais le secteur sanitaire en
difficulté mais je vous invite à prendre
la mesure de la souffrance du monde
médico-social qui a l'impression d'être
le parent pauvre de la gestion de la
crise je vous en remercie merci chers
collègues la parole à monsieur olivier
ferrand ministre des solidarités et de
la santé monsieur le député paul
christophe je vous remercie pour votre
question sur la question des tests j'ai
déjà un peu répondu je vais peut-être
bifurqué sur d'autres choses d'autres
points de votre question multiples
d'abord vous dire que nous n'avons pas
choisi les difficultés matérielles que
nous rencontrons nous les subissons
qu'il s'agisse des masques qu'il
s'agisse parfois des réactifs
évidemment ce n'est pas un choix et je
peux vous garantir je peux vous assurer
je peux vous promettre que nous mettons
tout en oeuvre depuis le premier jour
pour que notre industrie soit capable de
faire face elle tourne h24 et je
remercie aussi des industriels de notre
pays
ceux à qui nous avons passé des
commandes ou ceux qui spontanément ont
décidé de réorienter leur production
vers du gel hydroalcoolique vers des
masques père des gants verde sur
mulhouse vers tout ce matériel du
quotidien que nous n'avions pas en
quantité suffisante dans notre pays
quand l'épidémie a commencé
mais même avant qu'elle commence et que
nous avons anticipé en passant des
commandes partout où c'est possible à
l'heure à laquelle je vous parle nous
attendons des arrivées en provenance de
chine des arrivées en provenance d'états
zitte des états unis et nous avons une
cellule logistique qui est là pour
apporter le maximum de choses
nécessaires notamment la question des
réactifs pour les tests vous avez raison
de souligner qu'il ya des endroits dans
le territoire national où il peut y
avoir des tensions sur les réactifs aux
sur les kits de prélèvement à l'échelle
nationale nous faisons
pour qu'il y ait la solidarité à
l'intérieur des régions et entre les
régions pour que lorsque nous manquons
de matériel
il arrive très rapidement à nouveau
merci à la logistique merci aussi à tous
ceux qui se sont proposés de nous aider
à transférer dans les meilleurs délais
les petits matériels pourtant
indispensables au quotidien pour tel
hôpital ou pour tel laboratoire de
biologie
nous avons passé commande massive je
vous le disais qu'ils arrivent nous
augmentons notre capacité de test nous
augmentons nos commandes de masques et
sur la question des territoires qui est
une question vitale
j'ai insisté pour qu'il y ait tout de
suite avant même que l'épidémie commence
au moins un hôpital par département
capable d'accueillir des manades du coc
vide dans de bonnes conditions de
manière à ce qu'ils aient il n'y ait pas
de rupture de continuité territoriale
dans l'hospitalisation des malades merci
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur françois michel
lambert merci monsieur le président en
ce moment-même l'épidémie de kobe 19
progresse le nombre de malades
hospitalisés croît de façon
exponentielle
or bien souvent le matériel médical je
fais encore dramatiquement attendre au
nom de mon groupe
nous saluons la mémoire des personnels
hospitaliers et des autres personnes
décédées
nous assurons de notre connaissance
toutes celles et tous ceux qui sont
engagés dans cette catastrophe sanitaire
face aux pénuries de masques de gel
hydroalcoolique de respirateurs le
personnel médical et l'ensemble des
professions exposées sont démunis
s'angoisse quant à l' aggravation de
l'épidémie
cette situation nous alerte et nous
interroge à quelle date le gouvernement
engage et le renouvellement des stocks
stratégiques d'état en matériel médical
qui manque tant avez-vous anticiper une
éventuelle pénurie de chloroquine il
nous faudra aussi toujours garantir
l'acheminement du matériel
cet autre bataille souvent occulté celle
de la logistique la fiabilité la chaîne
logistique est primordial pour garantir
les approvisionnements nécessaires au
secteur hospitalier
au service public mais aussi à la
population aux entreprises je salue la
mobilisation engagée courageuse des
salariés de ce secteur vital pour notre
économie
le professeur jules 20 chef du service
des urgences de l'hôpital georges
pompidou le dit lui même
cette guerre est une guerre logistique
or la situation actuelle jettent une
lumière crue sur le déficit structurel
deux visions logistique qui existent au
sommet de l'état la france étant très
mal classés quand l'allemagne est la
nation la plus efficiente en matière
logistique et nous le voyons dans la
gestion de cette crise votre vision en
matière logistique lancé il ya quelques
mois
manque de portage politique qu'est
devenu l'ambition initiale de la
stratégie nationale france logistique
initié en mars 2016 par le ministre de
l'économie d'alors emmanuel macron sous
le gouvernement hollande
n'est-il pas urgent de nommer un expert
des diallo logistique auprès du premier
ministre comme vous avez un expert de
8,19 rattaché directement au ministre de
la santé
un expert pour redéfinir les priorités
organisationnel assurer la gestion de
crise et la reconstruction à venir
merci merci chers collègues la parole de
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé monsieur le
député françois michel lambert l'heure
n'est pas la nomination de tel ou tel
expert non l'heure est à montrer aux
forces soignante sur le territoire que
nous sommes avec elle et que nous
faisons le maximum pour répondre à leurs
besoins cruciaux pour sauver des vies au
quotidien
elle est là il est là l'enjeu et
croyez-moi des experts qui sont
mobilisés dans les territoires dans les
agences régionales de santé dans le
ministère dans les administrations
d'état
il y en a une nuit tu es jours jour
après jour nuit après nuit depuis le
premier jour quand même vous rappeler
quelque chose le la france est le seul
pays le seul pays à avoir procédé à une
réquisition total de toutes les
capacités de production de tous les
stocks nationaux en masque en tenue de
protection
c'est le seul pays à avoir réussi à
faire ce qu'on appelle un monitoring des
capacités de production des stocks et
des besoins de l'ensemble des acteurs du
territoire je suis allé deux fois à
l'europe une fois au conseil des
ministres européens
une fois dans le cadre du g7 santé
demandée à l'ensemble de nos pays
voisins de faire la même chose pour que
nous puissions avoir une gestion
logistique européenne de ces questions
parce que vous citez l'allemagne
l'allemagne fait deux fois plus de test
aujourd'hui que nous et nous allons la
rattraper en convergence je suis au
téléphone ou en visioconférence avec mon
homologue allemand tous les jours voire
deux fois par jour mais regarder autour
de nous les pays européens monsieur
michel lambert avant de dire que la
france est un pays qui étaient pourvus
regardez l'italie regardez l'espagne
regarder le portugal regarder l'ensemble
des pays de la zone euro
constaterait que la mondialisation
depuis des années depuis une décennie a
eu un impact sur la capacité des états à
se prémunir de la survenue d'épidémie ne
faut pas se mentir quand vous avez toute
la production mondiale ou presque qui
est localisé dans une région de chine et
qui se trouve que c'est cette région de
chine qui subit de plein fouet une
épidémie avant même qu'elle a qu'elles
arrivent en europe
faut pas s'étonner que les usines de
production thomas rade la france
j'ai passé des bandeaux commun pour des
centaines de millions de masques en
chine avant même que les usines
chinoises et rouvert avant même qu'elles
aient rouvert monsieur michel lambert
donc encore une fois encouragées les
soignants encore encourager nous a
accompagné les soignants fait nous
remonter les besoins des territoires
mais je crois que la notion d' expertise
c'est pas là aujourd'hui l'enjeu
l'enjeu c'est d'être capables tous
ensemble de se serrer les coudes et la
diète d'aller dire aux soignants qu'on
est avec eux merci monsieur le ministre
ma parole est à madame danielle obono
monsieur le premier ministre pour
réussir la mobilisation générale qui
permettra d'endiguer le plus rapidement
possible la propagation du virus
avant de pouvoir l'éradiquer nous avons
besoin d'une stratégie claire et
cohérente qui gagne la confiance et le
consentement de toute la population
ce n'est pas le cas selon nous de votre
doctrine de dépistage et confinement
vous avez décidé d'une réponse graduée
avec dépistage restreint et confinement
généralisée
quand d'autres pays ont opté de manière
constante et avec un certain succès pour
des dépistage massif et du confinement
ciblé jeudi dernier vous affirmiez ici
même que l'offre de dépistage était
suffisante dans cette phase de
l'épidémie
samedi presque une semaine après les
alertes de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé et d'associations comme
l'observatoire de la transparence dans
les politiques de médicaments olivier
ferrand a enfin annoncé une évolution de
doctrine avec neuf l'augmentation des
tests mais seulement une fois le
confinement levées
pourquoi continuer à restreindre le
dépistage pendant plusieurs semaines
alors qu'il ya urgence
dès maintenant les salariés des secteurs
essentiels qui ne peuvent aller
travailler en ont besoin de même que les
personnes confinées qui ont le virus
sans symptômes ces derniers mois votre
gouvernement a tenté de justifier le non
la non fourniture massives de masques
par des arguments souvent fallacieux
comme l'affirmation que les gens ne
seraient pas les porter pour finir par
reconnaître des stocks insuffisants
s'agirait-il donc là aussi pour le
dépistage essentiellement d'un problème
de production
selon le journal le monde la corée a pu
en deux semaines et levé sa production à
2000 tests par jour l'allemagne
aujourd'hui procéderait à près de dix
mille tests quand nous sommes à peine à
cinq
avez-vous en fait adapter votre
stratégie aux maigres moyens que les
politiques autoritaires ont laissé au
pays au lieu de se donner les moyens
d'une stratégie éprouvée de dépistage
massif pour pouvoir cibler le
confinement
monsieur le premier ministre envisagez
vous de mettre en oeuvre la
planification sanitaire et sociale
nécessaire pour réaliser ce dépistage
avec notamment réquisition des unités de
production recrutement de personnel
développement de plateformes ouvertes et
de tests alternatifs relance d'une
production locale public de réactifs et
de matières premières de réactifs
sinon pourquoi si oui à quelle échéance
merci même le député la parole à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé madame la
députée obono les entreprises elle
tourne h24 8 et jours reconnaissez-le
parce que ils attendent de nous aussi
qu'on le reconnaisse sur les masques sur
les gels hydro alcooliques à chaque fois
qu'il a fallu prendre un arrêté un
décret pour simplifier l'accès ou la
production de marchandises
nous l'avons fait une réquisition une
réquisition ce n'est pas neutre
une réquisition total de tous les stocks
et capacités de production ça fait
combien de temps que ce n'était pas
arrivé dans notre pays mais n'a beau
bonhomme je sais que vous êtes sensibles
ya une chose à laquelle je sais que vous
êtes sensible également ses les libertés
individuelles et collectives vous citer
l'exemple de la corée c'est vrai que la
corée dispose depuis quelques années
d'une capacité de dépistage comme aucun
autre pays au monde parce que la corée a
affronté des épidémies au comme aucun
pays au monde dont acte ça peut être un
enseignement pour l'avenir mais la corée
ne se contente pas de faire des tests
mabono la corée fait ce qu'on appelle du
tracking la corée à équiper tous les
téléphones et les données personnelles
de ce qui était nécessaire pour prévenir
tout l'entourage lorsqu'une personne
était malade
est ce que vous êtes prêt travaux bono
avoir ce débat dans le cadre de cette
assemblée nationale est ce que vous êtes
très mal à maubeuge nos à suivre la
corée jusqu'au bout de sa démarche
moi je n'en suis pas convaincu y à titre
personnel je vous le dis non plus donc
attention quand on cite l'exemple de
certains pays qui sont loin de nous ne
prenez pas qu'une partie qui peut vous
arranger parce qu'elle nous mettrait en
défaut prenez l'ensemble de la politique
qu'ils aient pu être menées là bas je le
redis depuis le début nous avons suivi
le oms lorsque l' oms nous a dit
dépister les nouveaux cas dépistés à
chaque fois qu'il peut y avoir émergence
de dawn de circulation active nous
l'avons fait désormais l'om s10 parce
que les connaissances sur le virus
évolue mais là
nos la vie la vie la virulence du virus
la contagiosité du virus
la durée de contamination du virus le
nombre de cas de personnes qui sont
effectivement contaminés de cas graves
c'est toutes ces données nous
parviennent régulièrement et donc l'om s
est amené à changer ses doctrines et
bien nous aussi nous suivons le msd
chloé massadi de tester tester tester
j'ai dit dont acte nous nous mettons en
marche pour être capable de tester
tester tester
l'objectif du déconfinement ce n'est pas
l'alpha et l'oméga c'est que pour le
déconfinement quoi qu'il arrive il faut
que nous soyons prêts pour pouvoir
tester plus massivement mais nous
n'avons pas attendu le déconfinement
pour augmenter nos capacités production
de test et de validation des tests
encore une fois ce sont les chercheurs
qui ont besoin de vous emmener un
sentier qui j'adresse à bout c'est les
chercheurs que je représente ce soir
aujourd'hui dans cet hémicycle
merci monsieur le ministre la parole et
à madame stéphanie hadj et merci
monsieur le président tout d'abord dans
ce contexte inédit de notre travail
parlementaire j'ai une pensée plus
particulière pour l'ensemble de mes
collègues et des salariés touchés par la
maladie et leur souhaite un prompt
rétablissement
ma question s'adresse au ministre des
solidarités de la santé le président de
la république avec force a mis l'accent
sur le principe de solidarité intangible
qui doit nous obliger dans cette période
grave que traverse notre pays
il a ainsi témoigné de sa détermination
à agir pour que ce principe facilite la
tâche du personnel soignant auprès des
plus fragiles et notamment des personnes
âgées à cet effet par courrier daté du
20 mars les services médico sociaux
auprès des personnes âgées ont mis en
exergue leurs inquiétudes face aux
retombées dramatiques de cette pandémie
auprès de ce public
en effet nous déplorons d'ores et déjà
un taux de mortalité au coc u19 à
hauteur de 15% gravement illustré par
l'actualité puisque nous avons appris
hier la mort de vingt pensionnaires
d'une maison de retraite dans les vosges
à cet instant j'aimerais adresserait
toutes les familles endeuillées et elles
sont hélas déjà nombreuses mais plus
sincères pensées avec courage et
abnégation
les soignants dans l'hexagone comme dans
l'outre-mer sont mobilisés pour le
personnel intervenant auprès des
personnes âgées cette mobilisation
nécessite l'usagé de 500 mille masques
par jour avec la transparence qui
s'imposent vous avez clarifier la
situation relative au nombre de masques
dont nous disposons un nombre qui sera
augmentée par une production intensifier
plusieurs commandes pour 250 millions de
masse selon vos déclarations
au delà de cette question le personnel
qui soit en ehpad oued à domicile
montre des signes de grande fatigue et
témoignent de leur inquiétude quant à
manara bien leur travail
il démontre en même temps le formidable
dévouement pour ne pas laisser ces
publics fragiles à l'abandon en effet ce
sont déjà des publics dont on peut
souligner l'isolément
cet autre fléau que la solitude
s'accentue davantage par les mesures de
confinement puisque dans l'impossibilité
de voir leur famille monsieur le
ministre dans ce cadre pouvez-vous
contribué à lever ces inquiétudes et
préciser quels moyens seront alloués aux
personnels soignants pour prendre en
charge les patients âgés dans les
structures médico-sociales dédié par
ailleurs qu'à l'accompagnement est mis
en place pour les familles qui ne
peuvent plus rendre visite aux patients
du fait des mesures de confinement
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole et à monsieur milliers vers
ans ministre des solidarités de la santé
madame la députée stéphanie hadj et je
vous remercie pour votre question qui
porte sur l'impact dans les ehpad où
vivent des personnes âgées en perte
d'autonomie
l'impact du virus et de l'épidémie qui
qui les frappe
nous le savons le public des personnes
âgées fragiles avec des maladies en
perte d'autonomie
ce sont ces personnes là qui sont les
plus sensibles devant le virus nous le
savons en france comme partout dans le
monde
qu'elle soit d'ailleurs en ehpad ou à
domicile ce sont les personnes qui sont
hélas le plus souvent hospitalisés qui
font le plus de formes graves et c'est
parmi ces personnes âgées avec des
comorbidités qu'on trouve le plus grand
nombre de décès vous imaginez bien
madame la députée que la question des
ehpad est une question pour laquelle
nous avons une attention extrême en
particulier avec des mesures difficiles
à mettre en place difficile humainement
à mettre en place
lorsque j'ai interdit toute visite dans
les ehpad pour les personnes âgées qui
résident ce fut un déchirement
un déchirement pour ces personnes qui
souvent donc que leurs familles ou
quelques amis pour venir les visiter
mais c'est pour les protéger pour éviter
qu à tout prix le virus rentrer dans
l'établissement parce que lorsqu'il est
rentré
la contamination peut se faire vite et
sur un public fragile ça peut faire des
dégâts considérables
vous avez cité un ehpad avec déjà vingt
personnes décédées et des instructions
extrêmement clair qu'ils ont été données
aux agences régionales de santé pour
faire au fur et à mesure jour après jour
le l'état des lieux dans les différentes
et pas de combien d pad sont touchés par
le virus
combien de personnes sont malades
combien de personnes sont décédées nous
vont pas avoir toutes ces données en
temps réel mais nous voulons faire toute
la transparence totale
il n'y a aucun intérêt à ne pas faire la
transparence sur cette question là comme
sur le reste d'ailleurs des enjeux sur
la mortalité les maladies qui peuvent
frapper nos aînés dans les maisons de
retraite médicalisées vous dire que la
question des solidarités nous ne
laissons pas de côté j'ai annoncé hier
une mission confiée à notre ancien
collègue parlementaire jérôme guedj pour
lutter contre l'isolément des personnes
âgées en ehpad vous dire également que
j'ai entendu la demande des
professionnels du secteur médico social
qui portaient sur 500 1000 masques de
protection par jour ils ont désormais
cinq cent mille masques de protection
par jour c'est beaucoup et c'est bien
peu pour faire face à l'immense défi que
représente cette épidémie merci
vis-à-vis du public le plus fragile
celui des ehpad
merci monsieur le ministre avant de
céder la parole à notre collègue éric
straumann je veux dire combien la
représentation nationale se sent
particulièrement proche de tous les
alsaciens qui aujourd'hui sont au coeur
de la crise que nous vivons et combien
nous voulons aussi exprimer notre
profonde sympathie notre affection à
ceux de nos collègues que nous savons en
souffrance monsieur straumann vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le président c'est vrai que
l'alsace et en particulier du haut rhin
sont très touchées puisque notre
département est vraiment devenu un
département martyrs le haut-rhin
représente 1% de la population française
et on y recense 20 % à peu près 20% des
décès
je remercie le gouvernement et l'armée
d'avoir déployé un hôpital militaire de
campagne à mulhouse ce qui permettra de
soulager les urgences
ce ministre pouvez vous nous indiquer si
d'autres hôpitaux de campagne sont
aujourd'hui pré positionnés pour se
déployer ailleurs en france
je voulais aussi vous remercier de
l'initiative que vous prenez pour la
mise en place d'un tgv sanitaire que
vous venez d'annoncer qui permettra de
décharger les hôpitaux de strasbourg de
colmar et de mulhouse
je voulais aussi vous remercier d'avoir
autorisé hier soir l' usage de la
chloroquine dans les services de
réanimation
ce traitement aux offres peut-être on ne
sait pas mais l'offre peut-être une
chance supplémentaire de survie et les
urgences de mulhouse et de colmar la
ministre depuis le début de cette
semaine devant la gravité de la
situation sanitaire du haut rhin je vous
propose d'étendre l'expérimentation de
la chloroquine dans nos ehpad du
département nous avons des équipes
médicales volontaires pour participer au
protocole de recherche
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé monsieur le
député
straumann je profite de vous répondre
pour vous demander de transmettre à
l'ensemble des habitants de votre
département qui me fortement à
contribution dans la période toute mon
amitié
les encouragements et le remerciement
parce que des solidarités incroyable se
sont développées là bas je vous remercie
d'avoir souligné les moyens mis en place
par l'état des moyens exceptionnels et
inédit et je remercie aussi l'ensemble
des territoires qui ont accepté de
prendre en charge des malades graves de
réanimation dans des hôpitaux parfois
très éloignés de strasbourg je pense à
toulon par exemple demain à angers à
reims où le tgv sanitaire fera des
arrêts pour à chaque fois il est
hospitalisé des patients par dix je
remercie aussi les pays qui nous
entourent le luxembourg la suisse
l'allemagne qui ont accepté de prendre
un certain nombre de malades
vous m'avez adressé une question qui
portent surtout sur l'idh roxy
chloroquine j'ai reçu hier les
recommandations du haut conseil de santé
publique fondée sur la saisine de cette
autorité cette société savante qui dit
nous n'avons pas les preuves de
l'efficacité de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
ou d'autres traitements d'ailleurs à ce
stade il est donc dangereux
en l'absence de preuves de donner ses
médicaments
comment donnerait des médicaments qui
aurait une autorisation de mise sur le
marché
en revanche le haut conseil considère
que si en collégialité en collégialité
des médecins décidé que sur des malades
graves
en l'absence de traitement avec des
complications pulmonaires sévères
il estimait en leur âme et conscience
qu'il pouvait être donné ce type de
traitement eh bien il fallait leur
permettre et c'est ce que j'ai autorisé
je ne m'arrête pas là puisque
j'encourage était une clinique pour des
phases plus précoce symptomatique ou pré
symptomatique dans différents
territoires
je m'entretenais avec des équipes de
chercheurs ce matin encore
voulons pas passer à côté de l'occasion
de donner une d'identifier un traitement
qui marcherait vous dire seulement
monsieur trautmann que les cardiologues
m'alerte aussi sur le fait que
l'hydroxyde chloroquine peut entraîner
des troubles cardiaques
aux états unis il ya eu une personne
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont mais
automédication
prenez-le hydroxy chloroquine qui a fait
un arrêt cardiaque qui lui a été fatal
encore une fois oui à l'innovation
oui à la recherche oui à la recherche
effrénée sans limite de traitement de
vaccins par tous les moyens possibles
mais dans le respect des données de la
science et dans le respect de la
sécurité et de la santé des patients
parce que les français ont le droit
cette sécurité comme ils ont toujours
droit à la sécurité sanitaire en tout
temps pour toute épidémie donc l'usagé
hospitalier réservé à des situations
particulières aujourd'hui et demain si
nous avons des données cliniques qui
nous permet d'espérer aller au delà
nous n'attendrons pas mais nous devons
attendre ces informations cliniques sans
quoi ce serait totalement irresponsable
de ma part comme ministre de la santé
j'ai débuté merci monsieur le ministre
ce député
merci monsieur le ministre je comprends
tout à fait c'est considère
considérations scientifiques mais on a
des équipes sur place qui sont prêts
vraiment à faire des expérimentations et
j'ai un exemple précis d'un ehpad où le
médecin a pris l'initiative va
d'expérimenter selon pas d'expérimenter
de de donner ce traitement en faisant
probablement un ecg connaissent tous le
risque lié aux problèmes cardiaques mais
dans de nombreuses et panne on est dans
une telle situation que cette
possibilité qui est certes aléatoire est
une voie d'espoir merci merci monsieur
le député
la parole est à monsieur joaquim pueyo
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur mise de la santé
monsieur mini-jeux souhaite associer
également à l'hommage rendu aux familles
endeuillées et aux soignants qui paient
déjà un lourd tribut je souhaite saluer
également le travail des pouvoirs
publics tous les français engagés pour
faire face à cette crise et c'est
exceptionnel qu'il s'agisse des
personnels soignants des services de
secours des forces de l'ordre des
acteurs économiques associatifs sociaux
humanitaires ou de l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens qui travaille pour s'assurer
pour que chacun dispose des ressources
nécessaires pour traverser ce moment
difficile monsieur ni je tiens aussi à
apporter tout mon soutien aux mesures
sanitaires prises par le gouvernement
pour lutter contre cette pandémie
mais le rôle des parlementaires est
aussi de faire remonter les inquiétudes
et besoins de ceux qui exercent une
fonction de soutien indispensable dans
l'accompagnement de nos concitoyens
isolé dépendants ou exposées aux
difficultés économiques et sociales au
sein des établissements accueillant des
personnes âgées handicapées ou empêcher
les professionnels avec qui j'ai été en
contact nous fait part de leurs attentes
pressantes de disposer des protections
nécessaires
ils n'ont que très peu de masse de gel
de kits de protection ou de tests de
dépistage ces manques risque d'avoir de
graves conséquences sur la santé de tous
et sur le moral des personnels
particulièrement dévouée est disponible
depuis le début de la crise ses
préoccupations et s'exprime également
chez les professionnels des aides à
domicile accompagnant les aînés souvent
isolés et les habitants dépendant cet
appel émane aussi des associations
solidaires humanitaire des pharmaciens
des ambulanciers des professionnels de
secours des personnels pénitentiaires et
certaines entreprises plus largement de
ce qui assure l'accompagnement et le
soutien aux français les plus exposés
monsieur le ministre pouvez vous nous
donner des précisions sur les délais et
la planification de la distribution de
ces matériels de protection dans les
territoires et puis concernant
l'accompagnement des personnes les plus
graves les plus isolés les plus fragiles
ne faut-il pas aujourd'hui réfléchir à
un renforcement significatif du service
civique merci
merci chers collègues la parole à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé monsieur le
député pedio j'ai fait toute la
transparence depuis le premier jour sur
la question des masques et du matériel
de protection j'ai annoncé les chiffres
de stocks d'état qu'il nous restait à
savoir pas de stock d'état de masques
ffp2 et quelques 86 millions de masques
chirurgicaux
j'ai annoncé que nous avions distribué
70 millions de masques depuis la fin du
mois de février que j'avais décidé du
déstockage de 20 millions de masques là
qui sont partis cette semaine à
destination des hôpitaux des ehpad en
privilégiant toujours les territoires
dans lesquels la circulation virale est
la plus active
et j'ai également annoncé un déstockage
dans les prochains jours à destination
de la médecine de ville
je n'ai cacher ni les difficultés que
nous affrontions en maintenir en matière
de stocks d'état puisque nous avons
hélas nous faisons avec
et depuis maintenant deux semaines quand
je dis que nous faisons avec c'est avant
tout les professionnels de santé
évidemment que vous venez de citer et
j'ai annoncé en toute transparence les
commandes passées à l'étranger j'ai dit
quand j'avais signé les bons de
commandes et les stocks que nous
attendions j'ai également dit que sur un
marché international extrêmement tendu
où tous les pays sont en recherche de
matériel de protection et où les usines
ont mis du temps à repartir
notamment en chine du fait de l'épidémie
il fallait être prudent et que tant que
les masques ne sont pas sur le
territoire
je ne peux pas considérer que nous les
ayons mais virtuellement factuellement
des commandes pour du matériel de
protection sont passés en nombre bien
plus important que les 250 millions de
masques que j'ai annoncé j'ai également
annoncé qu' des stocks de masques même
des petits stocks
quelques milliers quelques dizaines de
milliers de masques il y en a à peu par
un peu partout sur le territoire et je
remercie les citoyens
je remercie les entreprises je remercie
des collectivités qui jour après jour
s'adresse à leur pharmacie s'adressent à
leur hôpital s'adressent à leurs agences
régionales de santé pour restituer des
stocks qu'ils ont réussi à identifier
parce que ces masques ils sont précieux
pour celles et ceux qui sauvent des vies
et j'encourage également les entreprises
les collectivités les parlementaires qui
le peuvent a sollicité sur leur
territoire tous les acteurs qui sont
susceptibles de faire venir des masques
une façon ou d'une autre par achat
évidemment ou par fabrication en
réorientant les productions des usines
vers la fabrication de matériel de
protection
les choses sont très claires
nous sommes tous mobilisés tous
mobilisés sur tous les territoires pour
fournir le matériel de protection pour
nos soignants merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur sébastien jumel
c'est le premier ministre le pays entier
entendu les mots du président de la
république sur l'état de guerre
sanitaire mais plus encore nos
concitoyens sont sensibles aux
témoignages des soignants en première
ligne dont je veux saluer l'engagement
et leurs appels répétés à rester chez
soi le confinement est donc la règle
générale à laquelle les français se
prête plutôt bien même s'il ne faut pas
oublier que dans cette situation il y à
les confiner avec jardin et les autres
avec fenêtre seulement le monde du
travail est évidemment confronté à cette
question avec d'un côté la pelle à
rester chez soi et de l'autre les
messages militants pour aller au boulot
cette contradiction se traduit sur le
terrain par des situations qui ne trouve
toujours pas de réponse claire de la
part des pouvoirs publics partout au
monde des voix de salariés dans
l'industrie dans la distribution dans
les services comme la livraison des cols
bleus qui ne peuvent pas télétravail et
qui dénonce le choix du maintien
d'activités ils ne sont pas les seuls
même des chefs d'entreprise qui souhaite
stopper la production pour protéger
leurs salariés indique avoir reçu des
appels des préfets des directs pour
poursuivre leurs activités protection
sanitaire protection sociale protection
économique vont de pair de mon point de
vue dans cette crise on ne peut pas
séparer l'état protecteur et l'état
stratège maintenir des activités non
indispensables à la vie de la nation
s'est fragilisé c'est fragiliser la
stratégie du confinement
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous vous
appelons à définir des règles plus
claires d'économie de crise a précisé ce
qui doit tourner ce qui doit s'arrêter
avec pour seul critère la santé à
mobiliser tous nos moyens économiques
pour répondre aux besoins d'équipements
de santé a nationalisé même les
entreprises du médicament menacée de
cessation à renforcer le garantis pour
tous les secteurs touchés de plein fouet
par la crise et ceux qui en vivent
d'une certaine manière la loi du marché
doit s'effacer
derrière la loi de la santé tel est
l'esprit de cette question merci chers
collègues la parole et à madame muriel
pénicaud ministre du travail monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
monsieur le député député sébastien
jumel
en fait vous poser de questions la
première c doit-on aller travailler
la deuxième c'est à quelles conditions
et comment en termes de protection de la
santé
sur le premier sujet il faut bien
comprendre que les soignants qui sont au
front en première ligne ils ont besoin
du soutien de toute la nation et je
crois que toute la nation est derrière
eux mais pour que les soignants puisse
agir
il ya énormément de métier derrière qui
sont nécessaires et sur lequel le
travail de d'autres salariés vont
permettre la réalisation de leur métier
je prends un exemple la fabrication de
médicaments
ça suppose un laboratoire une usine qui
fabrique les médicaments une usine
d'emballage des livreurs un camion
frigorifique des autoroutes de la
propreté de la réparation des véhicules
je peux vous donner les mêmes exemples
de l'agroalimentaire qui est un besoin
absolument vital donc le sujet de est-ce
qu'on peut arrêter le travail non par
contre et là je pense qu'on sera
d'accord on ne peut pas travailler comme
avant
d'abord et nous en avons parlé hier
encore dans notre appel quasi quotidien
avec les partenaires sociaux et on en a
parlé avec bruno le maire nous pensons
que dans chaque entreprise
il faut se poser la question qu'est ce
qui peut être différé ce qui est ce qui
est utile dans la chaîne de bout en bout
qui nous relient tous dans l'économie
c'est une chaîne solidaire en matière de
santé mais en terme économique ce sont
aussi des poupées russes et chacun et
dépendants l'un de l'autre
donc il faut pouvoir dans chaque
entreprise avec un dialogue social et la
clé elle est dans le dialogue social il
faut que chaque entreprise et les
partenaires sociaux l'ont appelé je les
appelais aussi que chaque entreprise
réunissent au comité social économique
si ce n'est déjà fait ou ses salariés
s'il n'a pas dans les petites tailles
pour discuter justement comment on
s'organise comme on travaille en deux
équipes au lieu d'une pour qu'on soit
moindre ombre os croisés comment il ya
un mètre de distance
comment il ya des pauses plus fréquentes
pour se laver les mains il n'ya pas de
secteur où il n'y a pas de solution
c'est pour ça qu'on a mis en place une
task force avec les meilleurs
spécialistes de sortie du travail de
nuit
d autres ministères je travaille avec
toutes les branches pour dans les jours
qui viennent
définir c'est quoi le protocole qui
permet la protection absolue d'un
livreur d'un coursier d'un cuisinier
d'une auxiliaire de vie
je crois que c'est comme ça qu'on fera
nation unie solidaire tout en protégeant
et en n'ayant aucun compromis sur la
santé des salariés
merci madame la ministre nous
poursuivons maintenant notre séance avec
des questions portant sur des thèmes
économiques et sociaux
la parole est à monsieur daniel
fasquelle merci monsieur le président
mais qui sont s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre
le coronavirus impacte nos vies ils
menacent aussi gravement l'existence de
nos entreprises et des emplois qui en
dépendent
certes des mesures ont été prises et je
veux saluer ici la réactivité et la
mobilisation du gouvernement
cependant il existe encore de trop
nombreuses zones d'ombré un peu partout
en france
on craint par ailleurs une fois de plus
un décalage entre les annonces faites à
paris et leur concrétisation sur le
terrain pour rassurer nos entreprises
nous attendons de vous des réponses
précises sur plusieurs points faute de
temps j'en évoquerait que quatre tout
d'abord sur le chômage partiel
il ya encore beaucoup trop de questions
qui se posent le gouvernement a en effet
envoyé des signes contradictoires entre
renforcement du confinement d'un côté et
invitations à travailler de l'autre
par ailleurs de nombreuses entreprises
qui voudraient travailler ne le peuvent
pas faute de clients ou de salariés
volontaires
qu'allez vous leur conseiller un autre
sujet fort d'inquiétude concerne la mise
en oeuvre du fonds solidarité pour les
commerçants artisans professions
libérales et autres indépendants comme
exigé en effet une perte de chiffre
d'affaires de plus de 70 % sur le mois
de mars alors que le confinement ne
s'applique depuis le 18 mars
par ailleurs quand concrètement les 1500
euros promis seront ils versée
concernant les loyers ensuite il y aura
t'il une mesure coercitive par
ordonnance pour faire respecter la
promesse du président la république de
suspension totale des loyers pendant la
période de confinement enfin quatrième
point au sujet des pertes d'exploitation
pourquoi refuser la reconnaissance de
l'état de catastrophe sanitaire demandée
par plusieurs d'entre nous récemment
encore par julien dive et moi même à
travers une proposition de loi état de
catastrophe sanitaire qui permettrait
mobilisés
les assureurs grand absent il faut
reconnaître de cette crise dans le
climat actuel fortement que si eugène le
gouvernement souhaite remobiliser
il se doit être me doit se doit être
mobilisé bien évidemment mais aussi
clair et rassurant pour ne pas ajouter à
la crise sanitaire que vit notre pays
une crise économique et une vague de
faillites et de chômage merci chers
collègues la parole à madame agnès
manière une hache et secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'économie et des
finances merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député fasquelle
vous l'avez dit il y à la crise
sanitaire qui nous marquent tous et il y
as derrière cette crise économique qui a
mis à l'arrêt des centaines de milliers
d'entreprises par rapport à cette
situation nous avons très vite et je
veux en remercier ici la représentation
nationale près des mesures puissante des
mesures inédites qui répondent qu'ils
sont à la mesure de cette crise
économique
ces mesures c'est effectivement le
chômage partiel comme vous l'indiquez le
chômage partiel
c'est un dispositif dont nous avons
poussé les leviers très loin puisque
nous sommes nous indemnisons jusqu'à 4 5
fois le smic
c'est inédit c'est la première fois
qu'on le fait en france et nous nous
calquons sur le modèle allemand qui a
permis de redémarrer l'économie
allemande après la crise de 2008 et par
rapport à votre questionnement
bien sûr que nous allons lisons chaque
situation au regard de son environnement
lorsque vous n'avez pas de clients
lorsque vous n'avez pas de comment nelly
difficile de démarrer pour faire des
stocks en revanche et je crois que ça a
été dit un instant beaucoup d'activité
aujourd'hui sont essentielles pour faire
vivre 67 millions de français qui sont
confinés dans leurs bases vie qu'est
leur domicile qu'il faut nourrir qu'il
faut soigner qu'il faut accompagner et
pour lesquels il faut aussi fournir
l'ensemble du système sanitaire
je vous je vous indique que par exemple
nous sommes quasiment au-delà de 100% de
production dans l'agroalimentaire ou
dans le sanitaire pour prendre ces deux
exemples là s'agissant du fonds de
solidarité je crois que les choses sont
très claires
soit vous êtes dans une situation vous
avez perdu effectivement 70 % de votre
chiffre d'affaires au mois de mars parce
qu'il ne faut pas oublier qu'au mois de
mars vous avez toutes les entreprises de
l'événement
elle du tourisme qui ont perdu plus de
70 % de leur chiffre d'affaires et qui
sont concernées soit vous faites partie
de la liste des commerçants et artisans
qui ont été fermées par l'arrêté du 15
mars
et dans ce cas là vous n'avez pas besoin
d'établir votre perte de chiffre
d'affaires enfin choisissant des loyers
sa vis-à-vis des institutionnels nous
obtenons des engagements vis-à-vis des
personnes privées
la difficulté c'est que vous pouvez
mettre une autre personne privée sur la
table et qu'il faut avoir une approche
équilibrée pour les pertes
d'exploitation et tatiana bossy
madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur le président jean christophe
lagarde
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre et douze interrogés
parce que nous sommes nombreux à nous
poser des questions depuis hier soir sur
votre décision de fermer l'ensemble des
marchés aux comestibles de notre pays
sans délai je m'interroge sur les
considérations scientifiques qui vous y
ont conduit
sur la méthode et sur les conséquences
vous disiez hier soir sauf dérogations
accordées par les préfets sur demande
des maires mais dans le même temps
quelques minutes après vous préférez
recevez un message comme quoi c'était
d'application immédiate pour fermeture
de tous les marchés ce matin ça pose la
question évidemment de l'indemnisation
de ceux qui avaient prévu de déballer
aujourd'hui demain et c est cette
méthode a été impliqué de façon brutale
même là où c'était sécurisé et même là
où au service pouvait constater que
toutes les précautions avaient été
prises tant par les commerçants que par
les maires pour pouvoir marcher les
laisser ses marchés ouverts vous dit
d'ailleurs que vous demander la
fermeture des marchés ouverts mais vos
préfet ferme les marchés couverts c'est
à dire ceux où on peut contrôler le
nombre de populations l'espacement entre
les uns et des autres sans doute sous la
pression des images qu'on a vu sur
barbès ou ailleurs à la télévision mais
ça n'était pas la réalité dans le pays
de la même façon vous avez affirmé que
les villages les petites villes
pourraient conserver un marché une
rumeur court que les villes de plus
grande importance
dès lors qu'un centre commercial se
trouverait à proximité n'y aurait pas
droit à l'avenir j'aimerais que vous
nous rassure y est sur ce point
d'ailleurs cette décision et là je parle
des conséquences conduit à amener de
plus en plus de populations vers des
centres commerciaux avec deux
difficultés le première c'est que les
marchés sont en général en centre ville
les centres commerciaux à l'extérieur
comment font les gens qui n'ont pas de
voiture comment font les personnes âgées
et de la même façon la promiscuité à
l'intérieur d'un centre commercial me
paraît
nettement plus potentiellement
dangereuse que sur un marché où on
garderait les espaces et vous
comprendrez toutes les précautions
enfin j'apprends car un gie ce matin les
centres commerciaux achète à la casse
tout ce qu'ils peuvent acheter qui était
destiné aux commerçants des marchés
aussi monsieur le premier ministre je
vous demande si vous pouvez donner
rapidement aux préfets les instructions
pour que lorsque les commerçants et les
maires ont fait le boulot pour sécuriser
leurs populations ces marchés dès les
jours qui viennent puissent rouvrir
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le
président la garde le les mesures que
nous avons décidé vise à préciser et à
rendre plus stricte c'est vrai les
conditions du régime de restriction de
sortie du confinement qui a été décidée
la semaine dernière et qui est entrée en
vigueur mardi des vous savez que jusqu'à
présent les marchés extérieurs ouvert ou
couverts marchés extérieurs et être
autorisée puisque notre souci il est
bien légitime
c'est de garantir qu alors même que nous
sommes dans une période de confinement
qu'il faut respecter strictement nos
concitoyens peuvent aller acheter à
manger ce qui est évidemment un besoin
indispensable
il nous est apparu au cours de la
semaine qui s'est écoulée que un certain
nombre de marchés
pas seulement ceux que vous avez cités
mais d'autres donné lieu à des mesures
insuffisantes d'organisation et placer
ceux qui vendaient et ceux qui
achetaient dans des situations qui ne
correspondaient pas aux règles de
sécurité sanitaire que nous voulons
faire respecter c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai été conduit à prendre le
décret que vous avez mentionné qui pose
un principe qui est un principe
d'interdiction mais qui laisse la
possibilité d'exception qui serait
l'ouverture de ses marchés
quelle est la procédure à suivre il faut
que les maires sont au coeur du
dispositif qui sont les mieux placés
mieux placés a en vérité que quiconque
pour dire que dans leur commune le
marché est nécessaire
qu'il constitue le meilleur moyen
d'approvisionnement en milieu
alimentaire et qu'il peut être organisé
en respectant les règles de sécurité
sanitaire que nous avons édicté ou que
dans tel ou tel quartier d'une grande
ville le marché de tel ou tel quartier
est nécessaire et peut être organisé en
respectant les règles de sécurité
sanitaire j'insiste là dessus
vous avez été longtemps maire moi aussi
je sais parfaitement que dans la ville
que je connais le mieux le ap
il peut y avoir des marchés certains
marchés facilement organisables et que
dans d'autres la disposition des lieux
la densité rend quasi impossible
le respect de ces règles mais ce sera
comme ça et ce sera comme ça partout en
france
le principe c'est l'interdiction
l'exception c'est la possibilité pour le
préfet après avis du maire et sur
demande du maire d'autoriser l'ouverture
de ce marché pour remplir le service que
nous souhaitons assurer à nos
concitoyens
je sais que la période se prête mal au
message nuancé
beaucoup de nos concitoyens aimerait des
règles qui serait soit tout blanc soit
tout noir d'une vigueur absolue sans se
rendre compte parfois que édicter des
règles avec autant de contraste si j'ose
dire
soit tout blanc soit ou non ça placerait
nos concitoyens dans des situations qui
sont parfois très difficile mais c'est
vrai qu'en termes de compréhension dire
tous les marchés sont interdits ce
serait plus facile
sauf que dans tel ou tel petit village
pour telle ou telle catégorie de la
population personnes âgées qui ont
l'habitude d'acheter des produits frais
à tel endroit et qui ne pourront pas se
déplacer très loin agriculteurs qui ont
besoin d'écouler leur production et qui
trouvent là le moyen d'écouler leur
production
si nous interdisons le marché alors nous
créons un problème qui est bien souvent
un problème supplémentaire et qui ne
pourra pas être réglée alors je sais que
j'ai conscience que ce message qui n'est
pas très compliqué mais qui est un peu
nuancé a parfois du mal à être entendus
et parfaitement assimilé j'ai essayé de
le dire clairement pour vous monsieur le
président la gare interdiction de
principe
mes possibilités sur avis et sur demande
des maires des mères est évidemment là
évidemment les mesures entrent en
vigueur
brutalement car l'urgence commande
mais j'ai la certitude comme cela se
passe d'ailleurs depuis une semaine
monsieur le président la garde que ces
règles vont être de mieux en mieux
comprise de mieux en mieux appliquées
par nos concitoyens car la vérité c'est
que nous nous focalisons parfois sur les
cas de ceux qui ne respectent pas les
règles de confinement parce qu'elles
sont particulièrement choquant bien
entendu mais nous pouvons tout de même
constaté mesdames et messieurs les
députés que dans leur immense majorité
leur immense majorité
nos concitoyens respectent ces règles
les respecte avec beaucoup de sérieux
avec beaucoup de conscience civique et
que c'est heureux car ce respect des
règles est indispensable et il faut
évidemment pointé ce qui ne va pas il
faut évidemment pointé les comportements
qui seraient inciviques
il faut évidemment pointé les
comportements irresponsables mais il
faut aussi dire que la majorité de nos
concitoyens a compris l'enjeu collectif
et respecte admirablement je le dis
admirablement les recommandations qui
sont formulées je vous remercie
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole est à madame clémentine autain
les mesures d'urgence sont d'autant plus
urgentes qu'elles n'ont pas été
anticipées
comment la sixième puissance économique
mondiale que tel se retrouver dans une
telle pénurie de masques de gel de gants
deux thèses de l'ide incubateur et alors
même que comme l'a répété hier le
premier ministre
cela fait deux mois que le gouvernement
se prépare il faut un plan de
mobilisation sanitaires pour organiser
notre réponse dans le temps les appels
au secours se multiplient sur le défaut
de matériel qui ce qui met en grave
danger les personnels soignants les
stocks de masques n'aurait pas dû être
détruit l'entreprise honeywell safety
n'aurait pas dû arrêter de produire 200
millions de ffp deux parents faute de
commandes de l'état maintenant
maintenant nous avons besoin d'anticiper
la fabrication en france
en 48 heures les tissages de charlieu
dans la loire ont par exemple modifier
leurs lignes de production pour en
fabriquer 230 milles par jour
alors quelle entreprise allez vous enfin
réquisitionné quelle chaîne
d'approvisionnement avez vous mis en
place les hôpitaux manquent de
bouteilles d'oxygène luxfer seule usine
qui en fabriquer en france a été
délocalisé en 2018 mais ses ouvriers
implore une remise en activité allez
vous enfin le permettre les cliniques
privées demandent à être réquisitionnés
qu'attendez vous la pénurie de gel que
dire les messages de prévention nous
demande de nous laver les mains avec du
savon ou à défaut avec du gel
hydroalcoolique
mais bon courage pour en trouver quelle
main mise de la puissance publique sur
les entreprises françaises qui peuvent
en fabriquer la france a entièrement
délocaliser la fabrication de
paracétamol quand et comment allez vous
relancer sa production
notre santé ne peut pas être indexé sur
le profit ce matin le ministre bruno le
maire a invité à faire preuve de la plus
grande modération dans le versement des
dividendes cette année
alors pourquoi pourquoi une simple
invitation verbal et non une contrainte
légale comme vous savez le faire quand
il s'agit de contraventions individuel
pour manquement aux règles de
confinement merci chers collègues la
parole et à madame agnès pannier rue
nash et secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
clémentine autain je vous remercie au
travers de vos propos de célébrer
l'industrie l'industrie française et
vous avez raison elle a été durement
attaqué entre 2000 et 2007 puisqu'elle a
fait disparaître un million d'emplois en
france et je me réjouis de faire partie
d'un gouvernement qui a fait de la
reconquête industrielle
un des axes prioritaires de sa politique
économique
ce qui nous a conduit à créer de
l'emploi industriel en 2017 en 2018 et
en 2019 et c'est peut-être ça qui
explique aujourd'hui nous avons réussi à
mobiliser les filières industrielles
dans ce combat contre le corps à neuf le
corona virus vous indiquer qu'il faut
fabriquer du gel et nous avons augmenté
drastiquement la production de gel
hydroalcoolique grâce à des entreprises
comme lvmh tereos pernod ricard ou
l'oréal qui ont permis cet exploit en
quelques semaines et je peux vous dire
que nous ne sommes pas à court de gel
aujourd'hui une liste est régulièrement
mise à jour est à disposition des
professionnels pour se procurer des
quantités importantes de gel
hydroalcoolique
nous sommes en train d'inventer des
masques en tissu réutilisables qui ont
des
propriété de filtration parce qu'il
suffit pas de faire de la couture pour
faire un masque il faut qu'ils aient des
propriétés de de filtration et nous
allons dans les prochaines heures pour
voir lancer la filière textile pour
justement produire chaque jour des
centaines de milliers de max nous sommes
en train de monter en cadence joly dit
sur l'agroalimentaire sur la santé mais
la question que vous posez elle pose
aussi la question après la crise de la
manière dont nous allons poursuivre
cette reconquête industrielle pour
relocaliser certaines productions car
nous n'avons pas attendu cette crise
pour nous intéresser à la filière
sanitaire c'était l'un des enjeux de la
mission bio qui a été lancé au mois de
novembre et nous sommes en train de
négocier des réimplantations ça c'est
concret ça c'est notre politique et je
veux remercier une ultime fois les
industriels qui sont parfois malmené par
certains certaines voix sur ses bancs
aujourd'hui ils sont au rendez vous
merci madame la ministre
la parole est à madame marie george
buffet je veux d'abord saluer l'ensemble
des salariés qui assurent les services
essentiels à nos compatriotes
monsieur le premier ministre dans les
temps sont incertains convient semble en
pause la culture devient une respiration
vital la crise que nous traversons est
une épreuve sanitaires économiques
sociales elle est aussi marquée par la
mise en silence de l'expression
culturelle classique à travers la
fermeture des lieux et donc du retrait
des scènes des femmes et des hommes qui
la font vivre partout sur le territoire
je pense particulièrement aux
intermittents du spectacle qui avant
même le confinement souffrait de la
perte sèche de leur contrat suite aux
restrictions
plusieurs mesures ont été annoncées par
le gouvernement je m'en félicite
mais elles ne suffiront pas à sauver de
la précarité bon nombre d'actrices et
d'acteurs de la culture le gouvernement
propose de neutraliser une période
démarrant le 15 mars jusqu'à la fin du
pont finement dans le calcul des heures
nécessaires à l'ouverture des droits
sociaux pour les intermittents du
spectacle malheureusement cette période
ne posera pas l'intégralité des heures
non travaillées l'interdiction des
rassemblements de 5000 puis mis les
films finalement 100 personnes a impacté
les salles de spectacle et les
événements culturels
bien avant les annonces du président de
la république du 15 mai
la culture est au coeur d'une vision
humaniste de la société mais elle est
fragile
elle a besoin du soutien de l'état nos
scènes nationales sont en difficulté
cela appelle la création d'un fonds de
soutien au secteur culturel
la baisse du quota d'heures nécessaires
pour toucher les indemnités et le gel de
la période s'étalant aux prémices des
mesures de confinement jusqu'à la
reprise totale des activités culturelles
apparaît aujourd'hui indispensable vital
pour le monde de la culture monsieur le
premier ministre
comptez vous aller dans ce sens afin
d'accompagner aujourd'hui et durablement
les intermittents du spectacle et le
monde de la culture dans son ensemble je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole et à
madame muriel pénicaud au ministre du
travail monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les députés madame la
députée marie-george buffet vous avez
raison sur deux points qui me paraissent
très important d'abord tous ceux qui ont
des contrats à plus court terme doivent
être protégés dans cette période c'est
ce que nous faisons dans les ordonnances
qui seront présentées au conseil des
ministres de demain pour les chômeurs en
fin de droit et cdd et les intérimaires
les saisonniers et est le sujet des
intermittents du spectacle là je vous
suis aussi l'art c'est quelque chose qui
est essentiel dans nos vies ça relie les
hommes s'adonnent sens et on voit
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'expression culturelle alternative qui
essaient façon inventive de continuer à
apporter quelque chose à tous nos
concitoyens dans ce contexte difficile
mais évidemment les événements les
spectacles ne peuvent pas avoir lieu
pour des raisons que tout le monde
comprend et donc le sujet des
intermittents du spectacle dans le
spectacle vivant est essentiel c'est
pour ça que dans les ordonnances nous
faisons deux choses la première pour
tous les intermittents du spectacle qui
évidemment depuis quelques semaines ont
vu les spectacles annulés et qui arrive
à échéance de leurs calculs annuels vous
savez que c'est un calcul annuel
individuel qui permet d'avoir les 507
heures eh bien ils seront prolongées
d'autant et systématiquement et puis
pour les autres pour ceux qui auront
peut-être qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas à
échéance mais arriveront à échéance en
septembre novembre et qui auront eu un
trou pendant une période bien
neutraliseront entièrement la période de
confinement pour que je ne sois pas
qu'ils ne soient pas de dire est
pénalisé et qu' on puisse repartir
ensuite enfin avec le ministre de la
culture franck riester nous travaillons
aussi un plan de relance non seulement
l'industrie avec bruno le maire mais
aussi de la culture puisque ensuite va
faire redémarrer et on aura besoin d'art
et on aura besoin des artistes merci
madame la ministre la parole de monsieur
michael nogal monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à madame agnès
manière une hache et secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'économie et des
finances madame la ministre
la crise sanitaire du coït 19 est un
défi majeur pour notre pays pour enrayer
la propagation de ce fléau et protéger
les français
le président la république a décidé un
confinement strict pour limiter les
interactions sociales
mais c'est aussi pour permettre ce
confinement dans la durée qu'il a en
même temps souligné l'importance de
maintenir l'activité économique dans
notre pays en demandant aux français de
continuer à travailler depuis chez eux
lorsque c'est possible ou en se rendant
sur leur lieu de travail ne trompons pas
c'est bien parce que les denrées seront
produites que les supermarchés seront
approvisionnés que nos déchets seront
ramassées que la sécurité de nos
concitoyens sera d'assurer que les
réseaux de télécommunication seront
préservés c'est bien dans ces conditions
que la protection des français confiné
sera possible comme l'ensemble de mes
collègues surtout c'est bon je suis
quotidiennement en contact avec les
acteurs d'un territoire
je vais aussi leur rendre hommage pour
le travail exceptionnel qu'ils opèrent
auprès des acteurs économiques
je pense aux services de l'état qui font
un travail exemplaire
je pense aussi aux chambres consulaires
aux organisations syndicales et
patronales aux fédérations
professionnelles
tous ont répondu présent pour travailler
avec le gouvernement sur la poursuite de
l'activité économique tout en
garantissant la protection essentielle
des salariés sur leur lieu de travail
vous avez déjà mise en oeuvre en un
temps record des mesures pour répondre
aux besoins de nos entreprises
sans jamais oublier les plus petites les
travailleurs indépendants ou les
professions libérales
madame la ministre nous devons quoi
qu'il en coûte éviter les conséquences
de la crise économique de 2008 celle qui
a causé la disparition de trop
nombreuses entreprises emploient la
solidarité nationale doit puisque jamais
joué avec à sa tête un état providence
réactif et proactif pour soutenir les
entreprises touchées de plein fouet mais
aussi préparer la sortie de crise et
l'accompagnement à la reprise économique
pouvez-vous alors madame la ministre
présenté l'action du gouvernement pour
maintenir le fonctionnement de notre
appareil économique ainsi que sa
protection afin de préserver nos
entreprises et nos emplois je remercie
merci chers collègues la parole que
madame agnès venir une hache et
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
michaël nau galles merci d'abord de
souligner l'importance et l'hommage que
nous devons rendre à tous ces héros du
quotidien qui vont effectivement
travaillées et permettre à notre
économie mais au delà de notre économie
par mettre à notre société de
fonctionner dans ce moment très
particulier et c'est effectivement dans
ce cadre que non seulement nous essayons
de comme l'a très bien dit madame la
ministre du travail de faire en sorte
qu'ils le font avec le maximum de
protection le maximum de responsabilité
et d'engagement de la part des
employeurs mais nous devons aussi être
aux côtés des entreprises et des
salariés qui eux ne peuvent plus
travailler faute de clients faute de
commandes
faute de perspective faute de trésorerie
et c'est pour cela que nous avons engagé
un plan massif un plan inédit pour faire
en sorte de limiter la casse économique
et limiter la casse économique s'est
limité la casse sociale c'est d'abord
donner de la trésorerie aux entreprises
pour faire en sorte qu'elles passent ce
cap difficile avec le report des
cotisations sociales et fiscales près de
35 milliards d'euros aujourd'hui
et cet effectif c'est aussi garantir
leurs prêts et leur donner la
possibilité d'accéder à des lignes de
trésorerie 300 milliards d'euros en
soutien plus 10 milliards d'euros pour
le crédit interentreprises
au dos on appuie des assureurs crédits +
2 milliards d'euros
en appui du crédit export c'est un
également maintenir ce lien entre le
salarié et l'entreprise pour pouvoir
éviter la casse sociale et redémarrer +8
8 5 milliards d'euros qui sont consacrés
au chômage partiel
c'est enfin ce plan de fonds de
solidarité pour les tpe les indépendants
de toute nature qui aujourd'hui sont
fortement frappés par cette situation et
qui se mettra en place et c'est une
réponse aussi à monsieur le député
fasquelle dans les prochains jours avec
un versement
début avril je veux vous remercier merci
madame la ministre nous terminons cette
séance à des questions portant sur des
thèmes divers toujours en lien avec la
crise sanitaire
la parole est à monsieur pierre henri
dumont merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre parmi les
nombreuses interrogations que se posent
nos concitoyens l'une d'entre elles est
particulièrement prégnante pour les
habitants du calaisis celle de la
frontière avec le royaume uni
il y a huit jours le président de la
république annoncé la fermeture des
frontières entre les pays appartenant à
l'espace schengen et ce ni appartenant
pas étonnamment ces fermetures même
partielles ne s'applique pas au royaume
uni qui n'a pourtant jamais été membre
de l'espace schengen et qui n'appartient
plus à l'union européenne
ce qui hier soir la stratégie
britannique de lutte contre le coït 19
étaient à l'opposé de la nôtre est visée
l'immunité collective sans aucune mesure
restrictive
depuis une semaine alors que les
calaisiens sont strictement confiner les
salariés du port et du tunnel mais aussi
les agents de la douane et de la paf
centre contact direct des britanniques
ou des chauffeurs poids lourds faisant
la traversée risquant d' apporter le
virus dans leur foyer déjà des employés
du tunnel sont prises en charge à
l'hôpital ou en 14 n aujourd'hui
le flux touristique s'est arrimé le flux
fret transmanche et lui identique à une
situation normale ce sont près de cinq
mille camions qui embarquent chaque jour
aux ports et aux tunnels cinq mille
camions qu'il faut contrôler cinq mille
camions dont certains arrivent des pays
bas ou la stratégie reste là aussi celle
de l'immunité de groupe monsieur le
premier ministre pour la santé des
canadiens et leur famille comptez-vous
limiter au strict nécessaire les
chargements de fred traversant la manche
déchargement de tondeuses à gazon
peuvent attendre des jours meilleurs
pour traverser par ailleurs à calais
vivent aussi 500 migrants sans aucune
mesure de confinement
alors que mes concitoyens sont confinés
l'état ne peut laisser errer ces
migrants dans les rues les transports en
commun ou les magasins du calaisis
etes-vous prêts monsieur le premier
ministre à ouvrir à une centaine de
kilomètres de calais un centre fermé
afin de contraindre confinement par la
force s'il le faut les migrants présents
dans le calaisis ce qui permettrait de
sortir des griffes des réseaux des
passeurs tout en protégeant leur santé
celle des calaisiens celle des forces de
l'ordre et de leurs familles je vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
à monsieur jean yves le drian ministre
de l'europe et des affaires étrangères
monsieur le député du monde vous avez
rappelé les épisodes récents à la
demande du président de la république le
conseil européen de mardi dernier a
décidé de fermer et l'espace schengen et
l'espace de l'union européenne en y
intégrant le royaume uni dans un espace
unique peut protéger et soumis à des
mesures de restriction de circulation et
de contacts il ya eu des discussions
avec le royaume uni qui a abouti ont
abouti au fait que les autorités
britanniques ont bougé leurs positions
depuis vendredi dernier
d'abord en développant des mesures
sanitaires beaucoup plus strictes
ensuite vendredi soir en décidant la
fermeture de lieux publics majeurs à
commencer par les écoles et enfin et
c'est l'événement le plus important en
décidant hier soir par un discours du
premier ministre boris johnson de
prendre des mesures drastiques de code
confinement sur trois semaines avec des
mesures extrêmement fortes dont nous
mesurons pas encore très concrètement
aujourd'hui l'application puisque c'est
très récent et j'aurai tout à l'heure en
sortant d'ici une année change
approfondie avec mon collègue dominique
grave pour vérifier la mise en oeuvre de
l'ensemble du dispositif y compris sur
la circulation et sur le transmanche
mais les mesures qui ont été prises
visent aussi à faire en sorte que à
l'intérieur de cet espace que j'allais
appeler confiné il puisse y avoir des
contrôles entre les différents pays des
contrôles intra européen pour vérifier à
la fois que la capacité des
transfrontaliers allait continuer faire
en sorte que la vie économique se
poursuive à vérifier aussi que le
transit de marchandises s'effectue dans
les meilleures conditions le plus
rapidement possible et qu'ils soient
vérifiées et c'est sur ce point
particulier que je vais avoir tout à
l'heure les entretiens avec le mon
collègue britannique pour harmoniser
l'ensemble de nos dispositions et faire
en sorte qu'ils n'aient pas de
perturbations supplémentaires
merci monsieur le ministre fils de
et et merci monsieur le ministre il ya
quand même deux questions qui avaient
été posées et deux questions quelle j'ai
pas de réponse malheureusement c'est à
dire est ce que pour les migrants
présents dans calaisis on peut imaginer
centre fermé une cinquantaine centaine
de kilomètres de calais pour leur
sécurité et leur santé celle des forces
de l'ordre premièrement et deuxièmement
est ce qu'on peut limiter ou pas le fret
aux produits nécessaires pour l'économie
la survie du royaume uni ce qui met
aujourd'hui en danger si on garde ce
rythme actuel merci au niveau de la
santé des agents
c'est le problème des questions qui ont
report de plusieurs et qui ne peut
permettre pas des réponses exhaustives
sur chacune d'entre elles la parole est
à madame laurence vichnievsky
mais question s'adresse à madame la
garde des sceaux madame la ministre la
non prolifération du virus virus corvis
19 et le premier impératif de notre
stratégie contre cette pandémie
la situation des établissements
pénitentiaires est à cet égard un sujet
de préoccupation dès lors que les règles
de du confinement pourrait ne pas être
respectée et à ce stade je souhaite
rendre hommage au personnel de ces
établissements pénitentiaires qui à
l'instar d'autres personnels travaillent
dans des conditions encore plus exposée
qu'à l'habitude
nous savons madame la ministre votre
engagement fort pour mettre fin à la
surpopulation pénale tant par la
construction de nouvelles places de
prison que par le développement des
alternatives à l'emprisonnement
nous avons pris connaissance aussi de
votre décision de ne pas faire exécuter
les courtes peines d'emprisonnement et
de votre volonté de voir libérer des
condamnés exécutant la toute fin de leur
peine ces mesures auxquelles le groupe
modem apporte son plein soutien comme
nous tous bien sûr seront elles
suffisantes pour désengorger les
établissements et empêcher des détenus
d'être exposé à la proximité d'autres
détenus à l'intérieur de cellules
collectives
nous ne pouvons soumettre ces personnes
à des traitements inhumains ou
dégradants au sens de l'article 3 de la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme et je pense surtout aux
personnes en détention provisoire
puisque ce sont les maisons d'arrêt qui
sont le plus en situation de sureffectif
une solution pourrait être d'exclure par
voie d'ordonnancé toute détention
provisoire en matière correctionnelle
avec effet immédiat pour les détenus se
trouvant dans ce cas mais je crains
qu'une telle modification ne dépasse les
prévisions d'habilitation de la loi
d'urgence adoptée dimanche
dans ce cas les instructions
pourrait-elle être donné au parquet
enfin qu'il ne recours que de manière
exceptionnelle à des réquisitions de
mise en détention provisoire et de
prolongation de détention provisoire
pour les personnes poursuivies en
matière délictuelle
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole à madame nicole belloubet
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
madame la députée vichnievsky
effectivement la question de la lutte
contre la propagation du coffee 19 dont
les prisons est pour moi une
préoccupation toute première
actuellement je profite comme vous de
cette question pour rendre hommage au
personnel à la fois judiciaires
pénitentiaires et de la pjj qui vraiment
font preuve d'un véritable courage à la
fois pour assurer la continuité du
service public mais également la
protection de nos concitoyens
bien sûr le taux de surpopulation
notamment dans les maisons d'arrêt et
surveiller de manière extrêmement
attentive je voudrais dire à cet égard
que la diminution de l'activité
juridictionnelle entraîne de manière
mécanique une diminution des
incarcérations actuellement par ailleurs
j'ai donné des instructions au parquet
pour qu'il mette en oeuvre le plus
possible les mesures d'aménagement des
peines et les juges d'application des
peines font preuve à cet égard d'une
véritable mobilisation est actuellement
nous constatons qu'il y à déjà 1600
détenus en moins dans nos établissements
pénitentiaires dans le cadre de la loi
d'urgence que vous évoquez j'ai je
souhaite également faire davantage
encore puisque les détenus qui seront en
fin de peine à deux mois de leur fin de
peine pourront effectuer est
effectivement terminée cette peine en
étant confiné à domicile ceux qui seront
à six mois de leur fin de peine pourront
voir cette peine transformé en un
travail d'intérêt général
mais ça ne concernera évidemment pas les
terroristes les auteurs de violences
intra familiales etc
en revanche je ne souhaite pas prendre
de mesures générales concernant la
détention provisoire en effet vous le
savez madame vichnievsky
la détention provisoire relève de la
compétence des juges du siège qui sont
indépendants par ailleurs cette
détention provisoire n'est généralement
ordonné que si des éléments font
craindre une nouveau passage à l'acte ou
bien des pressions sur les victimes
et enfin vous le savez la détention
provisoire en matière délictuelle
concernent des infractions graves
au fond il me semble que le dispositif
que nous avons construit est un
dispositif qui permet d'assurer à la
fois la sécurité des français la
continuité du service public
c'est un dispositif que je crois
équilibré merci madame la ministre la
parole est à monsieur jean lassalle
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mais la maison
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues une fois encore les français
font preuve d'une immense élan de
solidarité et de courage il en a le
meilleur d'eux-mêmes et notamment pour
aider les sans abri les associations et
professionnels
nous ferons face à des pénuries de
masques et de gels manque de nourriture
de produits d'hygiène des moyens de
première nécessité elle manque de moyens
humains
elle ne sommes pas en mesure d'assurer
la sécurité sanitaire des bénévoles et
des sans-abri eux mêmes je passe ici
aussi il a les mêmes terne aux restos du
coeur
je vais évoquer aussi avec émotion et
fraternité
les personnes vivant seules en ville les
quartiers déshérités améliorer râle avec
le confinement
elles se sentent plus souvent donné
démunis lafreux dans le besoin avec
seule compagnie seule compagnie
l'angoissent aussi monsieur le premier
ministre
que pensez vous faire pour donner aux
associations et aux professionnels nous
interpelle les moyens d'assurer le
minimum
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur julien de normandie ministre
chargé du logement et de la ville
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
jean lassalle
je vous remercie pour votre question
parce que ça me permet de saluer tous
ces travailleurs de l'ombre depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire on parle
énormément des soignants qui sont ces
soldats au front des personnes qui
travaillent dans le médico social
mais il ya également tous ces
travailleurs sociaux tous ces bénévoles
toute cette grande famille du monde
social qui travaillent d'arraché pied
qui jamais ne se pose la question de
savoir s'il est possible ou pas de
travailler mais toujours se pose la
question de savoir comment faisons nous
pour continuer à travailler et à prendre
soin de toutes celles et ceux qui en ont
besoin
par votre question cela me permet de
rendre hommage à tous ces travailleurs
de l'ombre comme vous l'avez dit ils
donnent le meilleur d'eux mêmes c'est ce
qu'a voulu manifester le président de la
république en se rendant hier dans un
des nombreux hôtels que nous avons
réquisitionné pour mettre à l'abri des
sans domicile fixe l'hôtel kellerman qui
représente près de 400 chambres au delà
de cet hommage que nous leur devons nous
leur devons surtout de les soutenir de
travailler avec eux de leurs délégués
des fonds de leur permettre d'avoir
pleinement la possibilité d'accompagner
celles et ceux qui souffrent s'agissant
des sans domicile fixe c'est la
réquisition d'hôtel que nous avons opéré
depuis maintenant dix jours
hier soir c'était plus de 3000 places
d'hôtel qui ont été ouvertes
ces deux nouveaux moyens 50 millions
d'euros qui ont été mis à disposition
également
mais au-delà de ces places delà de ses
moyens c'est de pouvoir consolider et de
renforcer les équipes qui donnent le
meilleur d'eux-mêmes pour continuer à
reprendre vos propos
alors ça veut dire pouvoir apporter le
matériel nécessaire et on sait que c'est
un enjeu incroyablement important mais
c'est aussi de pouvoir faire appel à
d'autres personnes qui viennent
compléter cette grande famille et je
voudrais notamment salué l'initiative de
jean michel blanquer rick desbriel attal
avec cette plateforme
je veux aider point gouv.fr qui permet
de donner de nouvelles forces de
nouvelles personnes pour aller épauler
ces associations la solidarité monsieur
le député ne doit pas être une victime
du côté de 19
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur stéphane tester merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'éducation
nationale depuis le 16 mars la situation
sanitaire du pays a nécessité la
fermeture des écoles collèges lycées et
universités pour plus de 12,7 millions
d'élèves et d'étudiants le travail à la
maison a succédé au travail en classe
l'école et les courses vont donc à
distance grâce au dispositif mis en
place par l'éducation nationale
cette continuité pédagogique est
essentiel et vise à entretenir les
connaissances déjà acquises par les
élèves tout en permettant autant que
possible l'acquisition de nouveaux
savoirs dans le même temps un dispositif
a été instauré afin d'organiser
l'accueil des enfants des personnels
soignants
c'était une nécessité selon les
différents échanges que j'ai pu avoir
tant avec des parents que des
enseignants des directeurs ou des élèves
des difficultés on peut avoir lieu
notamment au début pour assurer cette
continuité pédagogique en raison de
l'indisponibilité des différents outils
en ligne pris d'assaut par ailleurs
certaines familles ne sont pas équipés
d'ordinateurs et d'imprimantes et n'ont
donc pas accès à ces cours à distance
le confinement pourrait donc être un
facteur aggravant pour les plus fragiles
en creusant les inégalités concernant
l'accueil des enfants des personnels
soignants le dispositif le semble
efficace mais d autres professionnels
mobilisés pour notre santé pour notre
sécurité par dont le transport le
commerce alimentaire ou l'hygiène n'y
ont pas accès ce qui génère des
difficultés de garde pour ces familles
enfin au sujet des examens et concours
beaucoup de rumeurs alimentées las les
réseaux sociaux cela m'amène monsieur le
ministre à vous poser plusieurs
questions
tout d'abord pouvez-vous nous faire un
éclairage complet sur les différents
dispositifs mis en place pour assurer
cette continuité pédagogique
on y intégrant la voie professionnelle
et nous dire ce qui est envisagé pour
les élèves
dépourvu de solutions numériques d'autre
part est il prévu d'étendre le
dispositif d'accueil exceptionnelle aux
enfants d'autres personnels mobilisés
de nombreux directeurs d'école
s'interroge sur le suivi administratif
de la période que soient les demandes de
dérogations ou la fiche navette avec les
familles en vue du passage au collège
pouvez-vous les rassurer sur ce sujet et
enfin au sujet des examens et concours
peu voulu rassurer sur leur maintien je
vous remercie
merci la parole de monsieur jean michel
blanquer de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
test 7,7
question évidemment est très mais très
dense parce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
à dire autour de ce qui se passe
actuellement
je voudrais commencer par rendre hommage
à tous les professeurs de france 850
mille professeurs qui sont aujourd'hui
mobilisées au service de plus de 12
millions d'élèves
c'est en train de marcher c'est je fais
beaucoup de comparaison avec d'autres
pays d'europe ou du monde et la france
est regardée en ce moment comme ayant
comme étant un pays qui a été très
réactif sur plan de l'enseignement à
distance avec beaucoup de
professionnalisme
beaucoup de dévouement des professeurs
est donc cet hommage national doit être
rendu au professeur parce que c'est dans
ces moments là qu'on se rend compte que
c'est d'avoir un un grand service public
de l'éducation
ça passe vous l'avez dit par
l'enseignement à distance donc ma classe
à la maison aujourd'hui c'est plus de 2
millions d'inscriptions ce qui signifie
plus d'élèves encore et c'est un
professeur sur trois qui l'utilisent
c'est aussi ce que nous avons développé
au travers de la nation apprenantes
c'est-à-dire ce dispositif qui englobe
qui implique différents médias publics
mais éventuellement privé aussi pour
tout simplement avoir des contenus
éducatifs
hier france 4 a battu des records
d'audience avec le nouveau programme
qu'on a mis en place depuis depuis hier
et nous allons avoir des contenus
éducatifs de plus en plus riches
il ya évidemment le sujet de la
connectivité notre but c'est qu'il n'y
ait aucun élève qui soit laissé au bord
du chemin
donc nous voulons les équipes et pendant
cette période et faire parvenir des
équipements informatiques à tous les
élèves
c'est aussi un sujet de mobilisation non
seulement des collectivités locales mais
aussi du monde associatif dans le cadre
de la plate forme dont julien de
normandie vient de rappeler l'existence
que nous avons lancé avec gabriella
talent et puis en second lieu il ya
l'accueil des enfants de personnel
soignant il se réalise pour environ 30
mille enfants par jour
nous l'avons aussi étendu au mercredi et
au samedi et dimanche là aussi non
seulement grâce au volontariat des
professeurs mais aussi des personnels
des collectivités locales et du monde
associatif
s'agissant et donc des mères les
collectivités locales s'agissant des
de toute la suite des procédures c'est à
dire la vie administrative normale de
l'éducation nationale je discute cette
semaine j'ai chanté les conférences
toute la journée avec les différents
syndicats pour assurer le plus possible
le report des examens et concours dans
des dates qui ne laisseront pas les
candidats nous communiquons avec
frédéric vidal aujourd'hui même sur
cette question merci monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à monsieur philippe michel
claes bauer monsieur le président merci
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre mais permettez moi avant de
s'impliquer dans ma question mes
camarades modem de la commission de la
défense josy poeyto jean pierre
cubertafon fabien lainé stéphane boudu
et patrick loiseau comme tous les
membres de la commission de la défense
dont ceux qui sont ici très assidus très
impliqués dans ces questions liées à nos
forces armées
madame la ministre au mois de mai de
l'an 2000
le premier exercice sur sol français de
l'otan voulue par feu le président
jacques chirac coopérative lantern 2000
conduit par le co fait et l'état major
de force numéro 3 déployés sur le
territoire du var et de fréjus
un exercice qui avait pour thème le
confinement de population et
l'organisation de postes médicaux
avancés avec l'improvisation de 2,2
points de vaccination improvisé dans des
lycées des écoles et d'autres lieux
disponibles
et force est de constater que 20 ans
après cet exercice voit la réalité
largement le dépasser sur un théâtre
beaucoup plus vaste pendant ces vingt
ans des procédures ont été mises en
place des standards ont été développées
comme orphée que nous avons découvert
ces jours ci aussi madame la ministre
pouvait vous auprès de la représentation
nationale dressé une liste la plus
exhaustive possible des moyens humains
et capacitaires que le président de la
république le chef de l'état chef des
armées aurait ordonné de le mettre en
oeuvre
face à cette crise merci merci chers
collègues la parole de madame florence
par les milices pour désarmer merci
monsieur le président monsieur le député
avant de vous répondre précisément je
voudrais à mon tour salué
l'exceptionnelle engagement de tous nos
soignants médecins infirmières aides
soignants et je voudrais dire qu'eux
aussi sont des soldats ils luttent en
première ligne contre le coc vie 19
et si vous m'y autorise et ils font de
nos vies leur combat pour reprendre la
devise du service de santé des armées
et donc je veux à nouveau leur dire
merci alors pour répondre directement à
votre question le président la
république a déclaré que nous étions en
guerre
et lorsque l'on est en guerre et bien il
faut déployer tous les moyens qui sont
disponibles c'est ainsi que pour
soulager les hôpitaux en particulier du
grand test et de corse qui sont en état
de saturation nous avons mobilisé des
moyens inédits d'abord avec le
déploiement d'un a330 phoenix s'inquiète
un avion ravitailleur et qui s'est
transformé en véritable hôpital volant
grâce à ce kit morphée qui a permis
d'assurer plusieurs rotations vers les
hôpitaux de laveran et de sainte anne
dans le bac à verre le bordeaux est
aujourd'hui même vers brest
nous avons également déployé un porte
hélicoptères tonnerre à la demande du
président de la république qui a permis
de transporter 12 patients depuis la
corse pour les romains ramener dans les
hôpitaux de paca et puis enfin à
mulhouse
c'est un véritable hôpital de campagne
susceptible d'accueillir 30 patients en
réanimation qui a été construit de
toutes pièces et qui en ce moment-même
accueille son premier patient
donc monsieur le député je crois que
lorsque nous sommes que lorsque l'on est
confronté à une pareille à une pareille
crise eh bien il faut se serrer les
coudes monter en première ligne et les
armes et les armes et répondent
présentes et une fois encore elle y
réponde et elles continueront d'y
répondre
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
madame brigitte les hommes merci
monsieur le président permettez moi au
préalable de rendre hommage à tout le
personnel soignant mais également avoir
une pensée pour les malades et également
ceux qui ont perdu un proche
et puisque ma question a trait à
l'europe je voudrais aussi avoir une
pensée pour nos amis italiens espagnols
qui sont très durement touché ma
question s'adresse donc à
ce genre l'odeur ministre de l'europe et
des affaires étrangères j'y associe mes
collègues jean charles larsonneur et
jacques krabal monsieur ministre
l'europe vit un moment inédit de son
histoire elle est aujourd'hui le premier
foyer de propagation du coït 19 au monde
avec 178 1000 cas et près de 10 mille
décès déplorés
cette crise sanitaire mondiale nous
rappelle la nécessité impérieuse de
l'unité celle de la france mais aussi
celle de l'europe l'union européenne est
aujourd'hui en ordre de bataille
la france a impulsé un conseil européen
exceptionnel la semaine dernière et des
mesures fortes ont été actés d'abord en
matière sanitaire
les 27 ministres de la santé
s'entretiennent chaque jour pour adapter
une réponse collective face à l'urgence
également en matière d'équipement des
marchés communs sont organisés pour
préserver nos soignants qui comme on le
sait sont en première ligne en matière
d'économie également nous faisons face à
beaucoup d'instabilité et d'inquiétude
et là je pense en particulier à nos
indépendant est à noter pe c'est
pourquoi la commission européenne
acter une mobilisation sans précédent
pour apporter des garanties et de la
liquidité à nos entreprises
enfin en matière de recherche notre
effort européen santé s'intensifie pour
répondre aux besoins urgents de notre
communauté scientifique
il s'agit là d'une priorité absolue
plusieurs grands tests cliniques ont
débuté hier et donneront les premiers
résultats d'ici une quinzaine de jours
ils permettront de mesurer les effets de
la coquine et d'autres traitements
associés ou non à très grande échelle
suite à d'autres essais je pense
notamment à une étude française plus
restreinte
monsieur le ministre en vue du prochain
conseil européen qui s'ouvre jeudi
que pouvez vous apporter de plus à notre
connaissance en matière de santé
d'économie et de recherche
merci merci mono député la parole est à
monsieur jean yves le drian ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères si
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés madame la députée brigitte l'iso
il y a eu lieu hier très longuement une
réunion des ministres affaires
étrangères des vingt-sept autour du haut
représentant monsieur borel il y aura
vous l'avez
indiqué après demain une nouvelle
réunion du conseil européen des chefs
d'état et de gouvernement les points de
discussion de mobilisation et de
coordination sont nombreux mois j'en
retiens surtout 4 le premier c'est
d'assurer entre nous la bonne
coordination la bonne complémentarité la
bonne cohérence du retour de nos
ressortissants
que ce soit à partir du niveau central
pour établir des cartographies de lieux
où il faut intervenir que ce soit au
niveau local
aéroports ports et aéroports pour faire
en sorte qu'ils aient des réponses
communes approprié c'est le premier
sujet le deuxième sujet c'est la
coopération et le renforcement de
l'action commune au niveau sanitaire
vous avez indiqué que les ministres de
la santé même si c'est pas dans les
compétences de l'union européenne se
voient régulièrement se rencontrent se
parlent pour échanger les informations
sur les mesures à prendre mais il ya eu
aussi des actions communes pour la mise
en commun de moyens les achats groupés
de matériel de protection la mise en
oeuvre d'un vrai paquet de recherche qui
a été initiée le troisième sujet mais il
est le plus connu c'est l'adoption d'un
paquet sans précédent pour soutenir
l'économie réelle que soient les
entreprises où le soutien aux salariés
avec les mobilisations financière que
vous connaissez et surtout
l'assouplissement des règles que ce soit
les aides d'état où que ce soit la
modification des règles du pacte de
stabilité et de croissance mais un
dernier point devrait souligner dont on
ne parle pas assez maintenant et que
nous avons évoqué longuement hier c'est
celui de la coopération internationale
et de soutien indispensable à apporter
aux pays tiers les plus vulnérables
parce qu'il faut en avoir très vite
besoin je pense en particulier à
l'afrique et nous aurons l'occasion je
pense de mobiliser un vrai paquet
financier d'assistance pour éviter que
l'épidémie ne mute vers des régions ou
des continents qui aujourd'hui ne sont
pas contaminés mais qui demain pourrait
être un nouveau risque pour nous c'est
une question à la fois de solidarité
mais c'est aussi une question d'intérêt
pour notre sécurité
merci monsieur le ministre la science
des questions au gouvernement est
terminée
je vous remercie de sortir de manière
échelonnée prochaine séance mardi 31
mars à 15h questions au gouvernement
la séance est levée